This is the Chris Abraham show.
Welcome to the Chris Abraham
show season 4, episode 27.
I think that's bent this yet.
They, or is it Z burn wounds
fancy Z born in Swansea, or is
it van set then set that set Jin
SE passe?
I thought I would start this
right when that vehicle decided
that I was going to go, BP, BP
back backup.
Hopefully it stops.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, welcome back.
I am underdressed and I am cold
while it's 63 degrees.
Here in Arlington Virginia, it
is also super little bit rainy.
Super like overcast little bit,
one of those cold windy days not
like a humid muggy winter day.
I mean autumn day They, but it's
a total autumn day, but I'm
still in a black t-shirt and
shorts.
So I am cold.
I cannot deny.
Luckily, it's not raining
anymore.
I had my lunch in a bus.
Stop shelter on Walter Reed
Drive and that's where I came up
with today's episode.
It is about Hunger.
Hunga hunga And what it's like
to be full.
And the fact that I feel like I
got full before I ate everything
today, and that might be one of
the side effects of what my
cardiologist is doing with me,
on this carnivore diet, which is
trying to reset everything.
Reset, my metabolism, reset.
My portions Set.
My addictions reset, my being my
allergens, my allergies, my, my
gut, biome, Etc.
So, that's what today's episode
is going to be about, I will
talk to you soon.
Welcome back.
My name is Chris Abraham.
This is Chris cast, season 4,
episode bente siete and bent a
siete veinte veinte.
Veinte.
A Bente East Bentley siete.
Hey Google.
What is the Spanish word for 27?
Cancel.
Cancel at anytime cancel.
Cancel cancel.
Piece of bugger.
All right, well as you know or
maybe you don't know my
cardiologist suggested because
of my obesity and addiction to
food even though I vanquished
all of my other demons drink.
Sloth, all those things.
He thought he would give me an
extremely strict diet for the
holidays.
So until the December 28th, I
think I am eating strictly
carnivore diet.
And what that is, is it's
exclusively fatty meat eggs,
salt, water coffee, black tea,
black coffee me.
Maybe a little bit of dairy
because that's also carnivore.
But purists all they eat is
fatty meat with salted.
Not even peppered or paprika.
Door, Chi end or any of that
stuff and water.
Maybe some salted water because
of I add Element e with flavor
to my diet because I've tried
the NT element additive that's
just salt.
Magnesium and potassium and it
tastes like, I'm drinking it
honestly taste.
Like I'm drinking saltwater,
fish water.
And that's it.
Really just water.
Black coffee and meat and eggs.
So, today, last night I put a
big slab of Chuck not Chuck yeah
like a big slab of roast into my
slow cooker and cooked it
overnight and this morning it
was done and I tried to eat a
big helping for breakfast but I
couldn't eat that much and I
tried I have like a big portion
in a vacuum in a vacuum
container, but I tried To eat it
at the bus stop and I only ate
half of it and it's, you know,
fatty and it's salty and it's
meaty and it's beefy.
And now I know what it's like to
be full.
To me.
It feels a little bit, like I'm
couldn't eat another.
B more or I'm going to feel
sick.
So dr.
Luck said that that's a couple
bites more than satiated but to
me it seems to be a binary and
usually I can eat until I'm
through everything and today
like I just ate a portion this
morning and then it's like uh
okay so I put the rest of it in
this This vacuum container and
brought it with me, and then
thought I would eat all of that
for lunch, but it just didn't
turn out that way.
And so I thought to myself, wow,
that might be what satiate
satiate, see, hsieh T,
satiation, sassá, sassá, sassá
sassá sassá being satiated feels
like, and so I'm running with
it.
I closed up the vacuum,
container the thermos.
Of roast meat with salt on it.
That slow cooked all night.
So it's, you know, that kind of
breaking apart, kind of beef,
with the fat, not cut off, you
need to eat the fat in this
diet.
I didn't put any hot sauce or
anything, it was just plain and
I'm done.
I have half the portion left and
I'll probably eat that at 4:00
or 5:00.
It is currently 12:50 a.m. 12:50
p.m. sorry.
And there you have it.
I never knew what that feeling
was, like, I know that when I'm
sick, sometimes I'm off my food,
but I take it that people who
have portion control are
partially, just sort of a little
bit off their food.
So, you know, they like to eat
and then when it becomes
unpleasurable, which I assume is
their concept of say, shit, In
satiated or full, they just kind
of go off their food and don't
want to eat anymore.
I can't imagine based on the
idea of being satiated that it
has exclusively to do with a
certain level of komal do
discipline.
I don't think it's fully
discipline, you know, I don't
think my buddy, Keith, I don't
think he liked orders,
something.
And only eats, you know, 12
bytes of it because he's worried
about his pretty little his
pretty little cute figure.
I just, you know, my, I know
that my my buddy Mark is more
concerned over his figure.
At least he's honest in his
vanity, more honest than I am.
But even I know that in college
used to bloat on an entire
Pizza.
Lead it Night from, you know,
someplace up in Adams Morgan
where he would bloat on.
He called it bloat, but I know
now that, you know, he, he eats
to satiety satiety, is that a
word?
I do not know what the word is,
so that's why I'm replacing it
with two satiation or Tilly's
satiated.
It's a really weird feeling and
I don't like it.
I don't like the fact that after
Here we are.
I live in a city feels like
suburbs but I'm in a city sexy,
South Arlington, Walter Reed
community park.
There are no people playing
pickleball.
basketball.
Like I said, it's 12:50.
Whoo, there's a pickleball
players.
I do if you can hear that in a
distance but it's kind of like
totally gray.
Like, it feels like feels a
little bit like Berlin.
You know, a low ceiling of gray
clouds.
Oh, one thing I noticed today
and this is a complete aside is
that I appreciate Arlington
because if you're up and out
early enough, you realize that
there are mechanical gnomes
everywhere, there's mechanical
know Use in our mechanical elves
whatever you call them when
you're on DMT going around in
white, American-made vehicles
with the emblem of Arlington on
it and they are washing streets
and sweeping streets and and and
blowing leaves out of the way
and throwing away garbage and
cleaning up and organizing and
fixing pipes.
And taking notice.
And in other words, the reason
why South Arlington and probably
North Arlington are such to me,
shangri-la's or utopian areas is
because they spend a lot of
resources.
A lot of resources, go back into
the system, and I used to be
really impressed by that when
our whenever I was in Paris
because you know, you see the
Esprit de corps. of the leaf Les
Francais when they send around
vacuum trucks and Street washing
trucks and discreet sweep
streets, scrubbing trucks and
trucks that are giant vacuum
cleaners and dudes, like
vacuuming the garbage from the
curb and The Gutter and they're
generally you know, wearing Is
it white or blue or yellow?
I don't know.
But I don't remember.
But that kind of Esprit de corps
that kind of Jenna sake.
Why?
I like that that pride in in
that pride in in space in how
you come across that obsession
with beauty doesn't happen on
its own.
You can see that in Manhattan
right now Manhattan.
And I haven't been in a while.
But, you know, they just have
not found an antidote for the
smell of piss.
Not even ubiquitous.
What are they called?
Pretzel vendors, or or
ubiquitous Chestnut vendors
during the holidays, can can get
rid of the smell of piss and
garbage?
That tends to become the
olfactory reminder that you're
in Manhattan.
I knew that there was a little
bit of smell of piss in Berlin,
but that's only because the
berliners are so eco-friendly
that they refuse to ever you
flush the toilet because they're
afraid of wasting water.
So they do that to themselves.
Because if you know anything
about Berlin is they've got,
they've got all the water in the
world.
They're surrounded by lakes,
they just they've got so much
water that they could waste it
out the Wazoo.
They just refused to back to my
Hunger and my satiation, and my
fullness and my food nasai.
If these are the things that one
unlocks B by playing the video
game, nor Nat known as carnivore
diet is, I think it's less about
eating only meat or any type of
ideologies surrounding the fact.
Like you know, liver King any
ideologies around the fact that
we are in fact Carnivores who
periodically eat tubers for
macro nutrients, or whatever.
That we mainly consumed meat,
not even vegetables or leaves,
or whatever, leaves or leafy
vegetables.
I'm not an idiot ologists like
that at all.
And, you know, I don't care
about killing animals.
I don't even really care about
killing anything, you know,
we're not Immortal if we were
immortal.
Killing and dying would be much
more of a big deal, but, but
because, you know, we're pretty
much fragile Earth.
Monkeys, everybody dies.
So, getting in touch with, that
is just just Good Housekeeping,
but forget about the ideology.
I'm not like committed to saying
awful.
Things like salad is for bunny,
rabbits, or any stupid stuff
like that.
I would love to eat Eat a
universal diet of of of eggplant
Parmesan and pasta.
Marinara.
Medina De Pasta marinara or
pasta pasta.
Puttanesca for the rest of my
life.
But I am being ruthless and
rigorous and Vigilant about
this.
The only thing that I'm hacking
is I'm eating every morning in
pill for my meeting.
Whatever that husky us thing is
that, you know, gives you fiber
some sort of husk.
I forgot what it's called.
I'll let you know if I think
about it but aside from putting
pills filled with none,
nutritional fiber supplement
into my body.
I'm following this rigorously a
couple weeks ago when I was
starting.
I would sometimes add, you know,
hot sauce and then I would get
lazy and I put some mayonnaise
or I'd put tomato ketchup, or,
you know, I was playing it loose
and easy, but now, I'm not even
putting pepper.
Like, I'm just like, man, I got
to stuff this beef down my
throat.
I really like the taste of beef,
specially salted beef.
I don't really need hot sauce in
addition.
There's plenty of salt in this
and so I'm good with it.
I went through ice like I said,
I still have some of the roast
slow.
Slow cook roast beef left in
this, what's the brand?
Zojirushi vacuum thermos and I
still have half a canteen of 40
ounces.
So 20 ounces of Element e.
I think it's called like pina
colada flavor.
Hydration.
Mix.
And that's it.
I have a package of liverwurst
at home because I'm told that
liver is good for other types of
nutrients.
And, because I grew up with
loving liverwurst sandwiches, I
know they're processed and
there's some carbs in there, but
I heart be some liverwurst.
Last night.
I did have, I did cheat.
I had, I had Claussen pickles
and I had Za without zoellick
out.
Zotkin out.
And so I did have those things
because I thought that they were
maybe good for my, my Biome, my
belly bugs, but I don't know if
that knocked me out of
something, but I was feeling a
little fragile yesterday because
I haven't rode for three days on
the ERG.
Even though I promised I'd do
10,000 meters a day and that's
because two days ago, I did
something stupid, I was really
feeling peckish.
I hadn't reached Feeling full
yet and I went and I downstairs
and bought a package of beef
uncured hot dogs and have them
boiled them and ate them way too
close to beddy-bye and so I had.
So I had terrible acid reflux
and stuff and popped into
tachycardia popped into into
afib.
My I had a night of sweaty awful
Terrors and Yesterday, I pop
back in and I'm fine now, but
like, I need to remember not to
eat, you know, after 4:00 or
5:00 in the afternoon and that
really, you know, the trigger
for me is that, you know, is the
acid reflux that or the
inflammation or any of those
things that makes sleeping hard.
And when I have the acid reflux
and I don't sleep well, then my
body reacts badly, my heart
reacts badly, I think it, I keep
on saying Vegas nerve but I
think it's vague vague Vegas,
Vegas, Vegas, Vegas, Vigo nerve
and then my whole body goes,
don't bump bump.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump
bump, and I flirt with
awfulness, when I don't want
awfulness.
So, on that note, I'll let you
know how it goes.
But, I'm pretty psyched about
this and I don't feel a lack of
performance.
Anymore.
I don't feel the keto flu.
I don't feel like I'm being
tragic during the day.
I do not feel like Desperado
when I'm at the cafe.
I don't even feel like I'm
drinking that much coffee.
I had half a pot left yesterday
from my from my stovetop Cafe
boost.
Boo, Café Bustelo on my 19 cup.
If you will.
What is it called?
Mocha Express, I had half a half
a carafe left on that.
So I drank that cold.
I put it in the fridge.
Drink it cold this morning and
then I had two of my, you know
Coffee's at ID toes and then
didn't want anymore.
You know, I'm probably won't
have any more coffee today.
I'm going to, after I record
this, I'm going to go home and
work from home for the rest of
the day. and, Maybe have some
liverwurst or maybe just save
this, this salty meat, this
salty fatty meat.
I have two frozen pounds 2
pounds 5 pounds.
But the only only time I can
find 73 percent lean ground beef
at my giant is when they sell it
is fancy Kobe. and in my giant,
it's actually quite Superior
ground beef, but it is rather
than I'm used to, which is nice
because it looks fresher but it
just might be red dye, number 6,
and it has a higher fat content
because most of the time bulk
ground beef comes in either 80
85 90 or greater percent
leanness and The carnivore diet
is a fat, a high fat, moderate
protein diet.
It's not a high protein diet.
It's a high fat moderate,
moderate protein diet.
So I need to maximize that.
In other words, when I finished
my salty meat, I dumped butter
on top of it, so butter.
Is actually to fortify the fat
content to make it as high fat
as possible.
So when it comes to condiments,
do not put a condom joke in here
when it comes to condiments.
I think that butter is better,
like everybody on this diet,
adds all the butter and so, you
know, when I prepared this
Zojirushi vacuum Thermos bottle
of beef When I was done, I
dumped in a bunch of butter on
top and that sort of just
infused the meat.
And so the meat tastes like
buttery beef, which is what they
serve you.
I guess at steak restaurants,
just do not cook the steaks,
just not really good at cooking
steaks on pans and doing all
that like, Browning blackening
stuff.
So, I've just decided to cheap
out and buy Fatty cuts of roast
and just throw them into the
into the slow cooker, give them,
you know, between 8 and 15 hours
and then see what happens.
Then on low, and then leave the
pans for this ground beef, you
know, which I.
Which I then believe it or not.
I put it into a cold pan.
I don't preheat it.
I kind of form it into the pan
and then turn on the heat.
And if I leave it long enough,
it actually is good because I
don't need to treat the pan with
any fat because when the pan
Heats slowly, it starts to
render the fat from the from the
beef before, it even gets hot
enough to start cooking the
beef.
So I it's almost like cooking it
in Tallow and then when I know
it's done and crispy, if you
know anything about cast iron,
ore or even stainless steel, or
any type of pens when you put
meat in a pan, there is what's
called a release point and
that's a point where there's
enough of a Char or enough of a
yeah a Char or it gets to the
point where molecular Lee it
does not it no longer sticks to
the Pan.
This is a problem, a lot of
people have.
They just do not let something
cook long enough for it to
release itself.
It happens with fish, it happens
with chicken and happens with
beef and it even happens with
eggs.
So on that note.
Yeah, my my next few meals are
probably going to be ground
beef.
Ground Kolb a 73% ground beef
and eggs and I got like these
eggs from giant that have like a
special Lee Vivid yolks because
I'm freaking tired of seeing
people on YouTube with their
frickin personal hens who had
these awesome bright, orange and
bright yellow and completely
Technicolor egg yolks that make
the eggs look so healthier and
the really lame pale convenience
store, almost out of date,
commercially produced chicken
eggs.
That, you know, I don't even
know if there's any nutrition in
there.
All right.
Mahalo, love you guys.
Evita Zane.
The next segment is going to be
how you can contact me, but you
never do.
I don't even know why I do those
extra segments.
How about this?
Fuck you?
You don't get a contact me
section this time.
If you want me to add a Content
section about how to contact me,
all y'all can do that by
contacting me.
Me and asking me to put it back
in there, otherwise no more
contact because I just say the
same thing over and over again.
Maybe I can hire someone on
Fiverr who will be willing to do
that.
Again, this is season 4 episode
bente siete episode Set once
fancy or is it?
Then we're gonna set all set?
I don't know.
I wish I remembered my
Portuguese numbers.
Anyway, it's episode 27.
I think your pulse just this
past yo, Creo que si Joyce pet,
OKC.
Jonah say auf wiedersehen to see
and I love you.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.